monsieur gilbert bun rany bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors on pensait le pic atteint en
belgique comment expliquer ce bond des
décès on va être prudent pour le pique
que je pense qu'on est tout juste dedans
mais on va être prudent on attend encore
quelques jours normalement les cas
n'augmente plus en tout cas dans les
hôpitaux il ya une certaine
stabilisation alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu un rebond de la mortalité mais nous
pensons que c'est dû à un retard de
notification de la part des maisons de
repos qui sont donc les ehpad comme vous
appelez en france les maisons de repos
et de soins
il ya eu probablement un notification en
bloc comme ça où vont du fait qu'il ya
eu un rebond on sait que le rebond à peu
près 170 cas des cds a été en fait
comptabiliser sur une dizaine de jours
précédents alors la semaine dernière
vous me disiez que le confinement avait
été imposée plus vite que dans les
autres pays d'europe donc ce n'est pas
dû à un relâchement de la population
belge ces derniers jours vous venez de
l'expliquer c'est peut-être dans les
maisons de repos les ehpad en france que
voilà on a mal comptabiliser le nombre
de décès est pas qu'on a mal
comptabilisés c'est que les comptes la
comptabilité ne se serait pas online au
jour par jour dont voilà il ya
différentes organisme qui recueille seul
et pc selon les régions
et puis au sein des établissements
la notification se fait peut-être pas le
jour même et voilà qu il y à une demande
de notification un peu plus un peu plus
nécessaire ou exiger voilà c'est arrivé
comme ça ont un coût alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya une mortalité qui est élevé
dans l'est les ai pas de c'est ce connu
je veux dire ça va avec la moyenne d'âge
de la population qui vit alors en france
la situation dans les ehpad et
dramatique quelle est la situation c'est
dans les maisons de retraite en belgique
comment le personnel soignant fait il
face à ces crises sanitaires est-ce
qu'il a tous les moyens pour répondre à
toutes les situations d'urgence et comme
dans toutes les institutions de soin les
soignants n'ont pas eu l'impression
qu'ils ont eu tous les moyens donc il ya
une inquiétude partout et notamment dans
l'est dans les maisons dans les maisons
de repos
effectivement sur le terrain et pas très
bien vécu
mais j'ai cru comprendre que le
gouvernement va mettre on va dire
l'accent sur les maisons de repos et que
dans la semaine qui vient de passer ont
commencé à les fournir en test et en
matériel de protection pour le personnel
l'idée étant de commencer à attester les
personnes résidentes danser dans ces
établissements comme premier point de
départ de l' usage du dépistage un peu
plus massif en france
emmanuel macron va prendre la parole
lundi soir pour nous annoncer que le
confinement est prolongée en tout cas
l'elysée il a confirmé déjà il ya
quelques jours est ce que ce sera le cas
en belgique on sait que le gouvernement
va c'est revenir mercredi
est ce que d'ailleurs ce confinement
doit être dur si dure si je ne pense pas
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
bon cela reste à confirmer mais le
nombre d'hospitalisations qui est pour
moi un indicateur plutôt fiable vu que
la mortalité taux de mortalité dépend du
nombre de cas à tester et donc ceci
n'est pas toujours très précis
le nombre d'hospitalisations n'est pas
en train d'augmenter
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi on durcir
et le confinement
je pense plutôt qu'on va commencer à
sortir du confinement mais et le
gouvernement
c'est bien de ne pas le faire de façon
chaotique comme cela a été pour la mise
en complément et donc il faudrait que
les tests soient prêts que l'ombre de
masques nécessaires soient présents et
que la politique ou la stratégie de
sortie soit redéfinie et je vais
rajouter le gouvernement belge a mis en
place
de travail spécifique pour la sortie du
continent
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
gilbert v jany d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
je rappelle que vous êtes anesthésiste
réanimateur et secrétaire général de
l'association belge des syndicats de
médecins et hop